all right I'll start with a quote here
just chaos total devastation and lots of
dead fish now that is how one guest of
the Radisson blue hotel in Central
Berlin described the situation after a
huge aquarium that you can see behind me
here in the hotel lobby burst early on
Friday morning about 300 guests were
evacuated from the hotel two people were
injured by flying shards of glass and
some 1500 tropical fish died now the
course of the incident is still being
investigated
this giant aquarium in a hotel was home
to around 1500 tropical fish and a
popular destination among tourists
the guests at the hotel woke up Friday
morning to the sound of a loud bang
the Beloved aquarium had shattered
it sounded almost like a firework but
the hotel actually shook inside
uh I I could describe it as a
and I jolted out of bed and turned
around and
I didn't see any movement so I didn't
know what the heck was going on the tank
with 1 million liters of water shattered
quickly
a large cylindrical tank in the building
behind me burst
there was a massive water leakage which
also caused damage to the building
the pressure sent debris from the
building flying into the street
rescue teams arrived
and hotel guests were evacuated
we heard a loud bang at about five or
six but didn't think anything of it at
the time
a little while later we got out of the
room and looked
all the elevators went down
and the lobby was completely destroyed
due to the abrupt League a large number
of fish couldn't be saved
the elevator ride with views of the tank
is now only a memory
and for more on this we can talk now to
Zandra Visa she's a German lawmaker who
was staying in the hotel when the
aquarium birthed thanks so much for
joining us here on DW can you describe
um for us what it was like to be in the
hotel when the aquarium burst
that actually I was not really aware
what has happened because
um I heard a loud bang when during I was
still asleep and then I had the whole
building was trembling and I thought
it's a small earthquake or something and
I just I was there I was listening but
nothing else it was a large silence
nobody screamed and so on and then I
said well maybe it's a bad dream or
something and actually I fell back to
sleep and when my alarm clock was
running half an hour later I looked out
of my window and then I saw there were a
lot of firefighters and police who
plucked the main road and then I said
okay maybe there was something and then
I started to look in the internet or to
look at the television and there were
already the message that there was the
aquarium who burst and so I tried to
reach the lobby but the telephone was
out of order and yeah actually there was
no Lobby anymore that's what I saw it a
little bit later
and I decided to to dress up to to get
my my luggage and and to try to get out
of the hotel and I was just in front of
my door and then three men for three
firefighters came in by a main key here
and they said okay you have to get out
of here we're evacuate and the hotel and
how were you able to get out I mean were
you able to sort of then go the the
normal way out or did you have to sort
of climb out of a fire escape
exactly we took the fire escape the
stairways uh followed by by the
firefighters and uh in the main lobby on
the ground floor there was water until
uh the angles there there was a lot of
dead fish
partly Frozen or really in between the
debris I wanted to ask you about the
fish because there were there were 1500
fish in that tank weren't there so I
mean were they were they lying around
did they did they were they washed away
I mean what did it look like
but actually they were lying around
there they were stuck in between the
debris uh they this nice uh parrot fish
the the large ones and and it's really a
Pity when I remember what is it was such
a nice image of you to have this
aquarium in the middle of this hotel and
and now you see it's it's a great
disaster
Sandra Visa thank you so much for
describing to us what it was like when
that huge aquarium exploded in the hotel
that you were staying thanks thanks for
speaking to us
you're welcome